marries with us in Chicago hi Mary
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thanks a
lot Dave how's it going today
better than I deserve what's up in your
world well last year I was involved in a
car accident
I was very ended on the highway and I
went through physical therapy and
actually had a concussion so I need to
wear special glasses and my injuries
that do come in and kind of interrupt my
job and what I do but the reason why I'm
calling is because I received a letter
from the opposing insurance carrier and
they said that they're trying to contact
me regarding a settlement of my injury
claim so I'm just wondering what is it
what exactly is that that a money
settlement I'm sure I'm sure they're
trying to settle with you do you have an
attorney representing you no I don't and
I don't know if I should show you it
sounds like it sounds like this is a
very very serious injury I mean it's I'm
blasted right I'm so severe and it's not
as bad as other accidents though I know
I appreciate your positive attitude I'm
talking about that prior to this person
hitting you from behind
which makes them liable you weren't able
to work differently than you can work
now this is affecting your income
potentially this has certainly affected
your health it certainly cost you a lot
of medical bills and yeah they need to
start talking about a settlement and I
think this is serious enough I probably
would have an attorney look over this
with you and represent you on this
settlement okay how do I go about
finding an attorney that will you know
represent me I know you don't have any
LPS with attorneys I've checked oh
you're right usually what I do is I
start asking around what among friends
that
like for instance are you are you a part
of a church I am call your pastor and
say who's a good attorney that would
give me a little advice on this and him
there maybe one in the church that and
that attorney may be a real estate
attorney and doesn't do personal injury
but they would have a recommendation of
a friend that this trustworthy and is
not just an ambulance chaser right you
know you don't want one of these hokey
cornball things representing you but you
do want somebody that makes sure you're
all of your rights and so forth our
address because truthfully insurance
companies very often will play you in
these kinds of things and you have some
legitimate things I'm not trying to
stick somebody for a bunch of money but
just just to stick them but you were
hurt and it's affected your life and
that there is a you know there's legal
recourse as a result of that and it's
not morally wrong to do that now for you
to act like it's a 30 million dollar
thing if it's not that would be morally
wrong right but but this could be you
know this could affect you for a long
time and therefore affect your income
for a long time and that's real money
that they then owe you correct I agree
with that so at once I do go through
with a settlement what exactly do I do
with that money if I'm paid up on
medical bills things like that do I just
roll it into the baby step so you
remember I mad yes okay exactly and the
big thing is is if there's a big lump
sum to offset your loss of income that
money invested would create income for
you that offsets the fact that maybe
you're not able to work like you used to
work or in affects you know the speeds
or something of your of your process so
that's what you're thinking of hey
thanks for calling in I wish I could be
more help and I'm sorry you've gone
through this what a mess